[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec Céline on vous propose
de découvrir un nouvel escape game au
donjon de Houdan il y en a deux et ils
ont été spécialement conçus pour les
fêtes de la Toussaint et alors Céline tu
es prête j'ai un peu peur je suis pas
très forte avec les énigmes les
devinettes et toi bah on va voir on va
faire ce qu'on peut on va voir ce que ça
va donner allez c'est parti
[Musique]
l'équipe à une heure pour soit trouver
qui entre le donjon soit aidé Gudule à
retrouver et à faire sa potion de bonne
santé et ensuite les gens ils vont
devoir fouiller chercher mettre en
relation certaines choses avec d'autres
comprendre qu'il y a des indices qui
vont avec des objets pour le fantôme par
élimination ils vont devoir éliminer
donc les personnages pour savoir qui
entre le donjon ou pas et puis pour la
sorcière ils vont devoir trouver par
dans la pièce tous les ingrédients de la
sorcière et puis il va y avoir des
petits pièges
[Musique]
la recette de bonne santé et je suis
fatiguée je suis fatiguée
un peu là non mais oh
[Musique]
super moment une heure on voit pas le
temps passer franchement
une belle découverte je suis très
contente de l'avoir fait c'est avec une
sorcière donc c'est dans le thème
d'Halloween il y a des potions il y a
tout un tas de de trucs en lien avec
Halloween
[Musique]
bon bah voilà avec Mathilde on a réussi
à résoudre cet escape game on a trouvé
les bons ingrédients pour trouver la
recette de la potion de bonne santé de
la sorcière c'est un escape game plutôt
chouette en fait à faire c'est plutôt
accessible pour les familles vraiment à
partir de 8 ans c'est faisable donc
maintenant
[Musique]